elon musk just took control of twitter
but not for the reason you might think
see elon started secretly buying twitter
shares back in january and in just two
months he'd accumulated more than five
percent of the company that alone wasn't
enough to do much with so he kept
building the position on april 4th
elon's big move hit the press he owned
nearly 10 of the company but sec filings
showed that he would be a passive
investor and not try and make any
changes to the company that clearly
wasn't going to happen though elon had
already been tweeting constantly about
how to change the service clearly the
pressure was on at twitter hq so by the
end of the day they had publicly invited
him to join the board of directors a
board seat would give elon real control
over how things get done but here's
where it gets weird if you look in the
wayback machine elon was actually added
to twitter's website a full four days
earlier so there's clearly more going on
here than meets the eye getting a board
seat is normally a key step in changing
the trajectory of a company the board
picks the ceo and sets the high level
strategy but twitter's board structure
is designed to prevent takeovers and
elon was thinking two steps ahead
twitter's now in a very public fight
with its biggest shareholder who is also
the richest man in the world so elon
declined the board seat and set in
motion a plan that would solidify his
control over twitter once and for all so
he's making an offer yeah is making an
offer to buy twitter you
made
an offer to buy twitter
why
in order to understand elon's plan we
have to dive into his mind and dissect
his motivations here because without
understanding why he's doing all of this
it's impossible to predict exactly how
it will play out there are three main
motivations for this type of corporate
takeover so let's go through them one at
a time let's start by level setting elon
musk is by far the richest person in the
world he has over 250 billion dollars
stockpiled from huge wins with tesla and
spacex so it wouldn't be crazy to say
that he's motivated by money twitter's
value as a company has been stagnant for
years now the stock price really hasn't
moved much over the last nine years but
during that time elon has increased
tesla's share price by more than 30x so
if elon could turn twitter into a
high-growth tech stock certainly he
could make a lot of money right well
it's not quite that simple see at 30
billion dollars in market cap twitter is
still a pretty small company at least by
elon's standards buying the entire
company would cost him around 10 of his
net worth if he then doubles the value
of twitter by improving the service he's
only 10 richer he would need to
completely reinvent the company in order
to make a meaningful profit and he has
way better opportunities in front of him
with spacex and tesla if he can just
deliver the cyber truck a little bit
earlier than expected he'll probably
increase his net worth by more than he
ever could by turning twitter around
it's also surprisingly difficult to buy
100 of the twitter shares even for elon
sure he's worth 250 billion on paper but
he can't convert all of that to cash
overnight he did sell 16 billion dollars
of tesla stock last year but he'd need
even more money to cover the full 30
billion required to buy twitter outright
he could go find a partner to help fund
the purchase but that might be tricky
because then he would have to give up
some control and banks aren't likely to
lend him enough money to do a full
buyout most banks capped their lending
at six times earnings but twitter trades
at 60 times earnings so debt could
really only cover 10 of the sticker
price now that elon has made an offer to
take twitter private lots of people are
speculating how he'll pull together the
money he needs to get it done but elon's
a resourceful guy and even if he has to
take out a massive loan against his
tesla shares he'll do it at the end of
the day this battle is about more than
money to him so we can rule out pure
profit as the main motivation here it's
just too complicated and wouldn't make a
significant impact on elon's total net
worth but maybe it's just a flex
billionaires love to buy fancy things
and what's fancier than owning an app
that 200 million people use around the
world elon has said that he wants to get
rid of his material possessions perhaps
owning twitter would give him more clout
than competing with bezos to build the
world's largest yacht i mean jeff bezos
and elon musk have a long history
together blue origin and spacex are
constantly duking it out to reach new
milestones and win splashy headlines and
jeff bezos did buy the washington post
in 2013 for 250 million dollars so maybe
elon wants to one-up jeff in the media
world and show him who's boss
twitter might cost a hundred times more
money than an old newspaper company but
it certainly has a bigger impact there
are two main ways to look at the value
of twitter you can look at it like a
business or you can look at its impact
on the world for most companies these
two metrics are usually pretty closely
aligned but not for twitter major news
breaks first on twitter journalists
celebrities billionaires and even tech
youtubers hang out there but as a
business twitter has been struggling for
years the company is so behind on
monetization that mark zuckerberg once
said it's as if they drove a clown car
into a gold mine and fell in twitter's
impact on the world is unquestionable
though so owning it would be the perfect
gift for the man who has everything
but the twitter board of directors is
already fighting back against elon's
buyout bid even though this story is a
big surprise twitter already has a set
of defenses in place that could make it
extremely difficult for elon to win this
is because twitter's corporate bylaws
are filled with special provisions
called poison pills the goal of these
poison pills is to prevent hostile
takeovers if you're running a public
company and you like your job you
probably don't want someone to sneak up
on you and kick you out without a fight
these provisions are common in
founder-led companies but jack dorsey
stopped serving as twitter ceo months
ago the poison pills remain though so
getting full control over the board of
directors will be difficult but not
impossible elon is determined to move
forward with this takeover but it's
going to be an extremely messy fight
with tons of legal red tape even if he
can get it done it wouldn't be nearly as
fun as building a new mega yacht so we
can safely rule out the idea that elon
is buying twitter as a crazy billionaire
flex so what about influence lots of
people are saying that elon wants to
take over twitter so that he can bend
the rules and drive more attention to
his companies it's pretty clear that
twitter is an important platform for
elon he has 80 million followers on
there and unlike most of the other
celebrities with massive followings on
there he actually posts viral tweets
regularly instead of just using twitter
as a press release outlet like most
companies elon is constantly building a
real community of supporters they watch
the spacex launches they buy teslas and
they amplify everything he says but
that's the thing all of that is already
happening elon hasn't been shadow banned
or de-platformed his tweets do
incredibly well and the idea that elon
could use twitter to manipulate tesla's
stock price just doesn't add up the sec
has rules about stock manipulation and
enforces those regardless of who owns
the social media platforms and the sec
has used those rules to fine elon in the
past he tweeted that he was considering
taking tesla private and quickly wound
up in hot water with the government
nothing would be different if he owned
more shares in twitter if anything the
sec would be watching more closely than
ever so if elon isn't buying twitter to
make money flex on bezos or increase his
reach why is he buying it well instead
of speculating let's just ask someone
who's worked with elon directly what
this is really about is free speech
that's david sacks who worked with elon
at paypal and is one of the many silicon
valley leaders who are pushing for more
free speech across social media
platforms over the past few years we've
seen social media platforms censor and
remove a wide variety of accounts it's a
complicated problem since at the end of
the day these companies are for-profit
businesses that means that if they can
make more money by de-platforming
certain accounts they're incentivized to
do so the problem is the effect that
this has on our society corporate
censorship doesn't actually prevent
people from speaking their mind it just
forces them to do so on different
platforms with no one to push back on
them after donald trump was banned from
twitter he immediately started working
on a new social network where he could
say anything he wanted this creates echo
chambers where people go to reinforce
their beliefs without ever being
challenged the end result is increasing
political polarization but elon isn't a
trump supporter and he's not at risk of
being deplatformed so why does he care
so much about free speech well as he
said in a recent twitter poll free
speech is essential to a functioning
democracy and this gets to the heart of
his motivations elon can only build the
type of companies he wants in a free
country as we've seen all too often
billionaires who build companies in
authoritarian countries tend to go
missing or wind up poisoned so elon is
fighting for free speech he's fighting
for democracy and he's fighting for
america but how is elon actually going
to ensure that twitter upholds the
principles of free speech well clearly
elon has no choice but to try and buy
the entire company he's planning to pay
43 billion dollars to acquire twitter
and take it private this is extremely
risky but could unlock big opportunities
elon is a massive talent magnet for the
world's top engineers and with him at
the helm lots of people want to go work
at twitter even though elon is only
offering a modest 20 premium to the
current share price he's already pumped
the stock 30
just by buying a small stake he
basically turned twitter into a meme
stock overnight and if the board
declines his offer he'll sell his shares
and the market will likely react harshly
twitter gets a ton of traffic every day
but their monetization strategy just
doesn't match the customer base that
they serve changing twitter's business
model would be impossible while they are
a public company but if elon succeeds in
taking the company private we could see
things change pretty dramatically
billionaires can buy lots of things that
average people can't yachts space
companies and even fine art at least
that was the case until channel sponsor
masterworks.org came along and unlocked
fine art investing typically you have to
be extremely wealthy to build a real
portfolio of fine art but masterworks
changes that by allowing you to invest
in world famous artworks from banksy
monet and other iconic artists for just
a fraction of what these pieces
typically cost this is important because
contemporary art prices outpace the s p
500 total return by 164 percent from
1995 to 2021. the entire category has
historically required millions of
dollars to access but masterworks has a
secondary market where you can trade
shares in fine art just like buying a
stock on a trading app getting set up
with masterworks is extremely easy you
just create an account on their site
browse their artwork and then start
diversifying your portfolio with one of
the most stable assets around i like
masterworks because it unlocks an
entirely new market and it actually
teaches me something in the process they
have these really interesting videos
about the history of the artworks on
their platform for example i recently
watched one on kusama who i'd heard of
but i had no idea that she was committed
to a mental institution in 1977 i love
hearing stories like that so go click
the link in the description to skip the
wait list and help out the channel and
if you're looking for more stories about
elon musk check out this video about
tesla's recent advances in artificial
intelligence thanks for watching